[Music]
talent is everywhere but at many of
america's top institutions black leaders
are still
few and far between that's the
conclusion of cbs news political
contributor jamal simmons
who reviewed publicly available data on
diversity at several u.s companies and
universities
simmons found the percentage of black
people in leadership jobs is often stuck
around four percent that's even though
13 percent of americans are black
apple amazon google and facebook report
their diversity numbers publicly every
year
and so we can see what simmons is
talking about in 2020
only four percent of apple's leaders
were black amazon facebook and google
were all hovering around 3 percent the 4
percent phenomena as simmons calls it is
a pattern
he also found among tenured faculty at
some of the most elite schools in
america that includes
harvard yale duke mit and the university
of california
at berkeley and as jamal puts it quote
it's as if someone has put
sticky tar paper on the road to african
american
inclusion and we should also point out
that these companies and universities
have
almost without variation made public and
significant investments and commitments
to narrowing the gap and promoting
diversity
and inclusion on a broad scale so let's
bring in jamal simmons now to talk about
all this jamal good morning to you um
the article is in a new journal or the
new article is in a journal called
democracy
uh and you make the point in it that
these
goodwill efforts by companies while
sincere have not so far
been very effective so what needs to be
done yeah you know tony um 25 years ago
i was a graduate student at harvard and
we had a racial incident on campus and
so we
confronted the dean of the kennedy
school at the time about why there were
no african-american tenured faculty
at the kennedy school he said for the
most part
it's a pipeline problem there aren't
enough people coming through the
pipeline well that was 25 years ago
there were none you know how many they
are today there are two
two out of 55 that's less than four
percent of the faculty at that school
and that's true for harvard-wide it's
true for yale as you went through
so i began you know as as george floyd
happened and brianna taylor and company
started making a lot of these statements
about commitment to
racial equality and dealing with
systemic racism i began to wonder do the
companies and organizations have the
teams
at their fingertips that can actually
deal with this very significant problem
and the more research i did the more i
kept finding that those teams are coming
up short and here's the thing
it's not just about one particular
company that's what was so amazing it's
about a whole sector
it's all about a trend that runs across
sectors i'll give you one story and we
can go to the next
colin powell was chairman of the joint
chiefs of staff
25 years ago we are all very honored by
that he was the first african-american
chairman
today 25 years later not another black
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
there are 41 of the most senior
commanders in the military who can even
be considered only two of them are
african-american it's about 4.9
so if you think about this like a
parking lot and you number the spaces
one through
ten most of the cars would be clustered
around space number four
and so it's it's not a ceiling it's just
sort of a cluster around four percent
and why
is it we can't really break through that
yeah the four percent phenomena one of
the points you make in the article which
i thought was compelling is that these
companies and the military all these
institutions
they look left and they look right and
they say well we're doing as well as the
other guys so i guess we're doing okay
but that's a false sense of comfort in
terms of their progress so how do they
push beyond that what needs to happen
you know melody hobson's been here as a
matter of fact she was talking to you
guys
back in february and she talked about
this when she became chair of the
starbucks board we got to attack this
problem from both ends of the pipeline
you got to deal with the people who are
coming into the pipeline at the entry
level
and make sure we have recruitment
recruitment criteria that allow more
people to come in
and then we've got to deal with people
at the top levels in the leadership
and what i find is most leaders many
leaders have come through black-led
organizations and so if we think about
building formal partnerships formal
relationships
through many of the organizations
whether they're historically black
colleges or people like melody hopson
right who got hired out of princeton by
john rogers she worked at aerial
investments for years
she grew there she flowered there she
became her own person there
and then she moved into board leadership
at other places right
we see that happen over and over again
darren walker who's at the
ford foundation who's the president he
was at the abyssinian development
corporation before he went into you know
rockefeller and then ford
we see this trend line i say let's
formalize it let's
build some of these relationships so we
don't [ __ ] those black-led
organizations when we cherry-pick their
talent
and let's bring some folks into
mainstream at the top so the candidates
coming up through the pipeline
have role models and people who are
building a culture that will enable
their success so jamal we all agree that
four percent number
ain't so good what would progress look
like to you what is the number that you
go okay
now we're doing now we're talking so
tony brought it up in the beginning so
13
of the country is african-american 10 of
college graduates are african-american
it just seemed so now we're at four
percent in terms of leadership
it just seems like we ought to be
getting closer into the eight nine ten
percent
uh range if we're gonna have parity and
one of the things as
tony just mentioned that we found i
found in the research talking to a lot
of people who
who do this work is you've got to set
clear goals about what you want
and then you've got to really lean on
policing what it is that you want some
great
professors did this thing about women on
boards you'll appreciate this
they found that uh that for a long time
having one woman on a board was
considered to be appropriate people
didn't think so
so all the companies looked around and
now you see a greater likelihood that
there are two women on the board so they
went from tokenism
to toucanism and they predict that at
some point they'll be threakanism
right because people will decide two is
not enough the same thing exists with
racial
racial diversity at the leadership level
jamal we're running out of time talent
is everywhere
opportunity should be as well thank you
very much you're watching cbs this
morning we'll be right back